[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir mon nom et jean meyer et il ya
37 ans j'ai été conçu à l'hôpital necker
d'un don anonyme des spermes et figure
pas le seul ce mode de conception a aidé
de nombreux couples stériles
on lui doit près de 80 mille naissances
depuis la fin des années 70 soit grosso
modo une sur trois sont fait dire que
statistiquement ce soir parmi vous il y
a entre deux à trois personnes qui
auraient aussi bénéficié d'un don
anonyme de sperme et cela sans le savoir
elle ignore encore parce que on estime
que grosso modo moins de 10% des enfants
issus d'une insémination artificielle
avec donneur en aurait été informé ce
qui veut dire que non seulement ils ne
connaissent pas leur père biologique
mais en plus ils sont au coeur et au
centre dans secret familial et ça peut
être n'importe qui c'est peut être votre
voisin de gauche de droite
ce monsieur qui se grattent la tête ou
tout simplement vous et je sais
exactement ce que vous êtes en train de
vous dire mais n'importe quoi moi c'est
impossible je ressemble trop à mon père
je pensais la même chose moi aussi je
ressemble à mon père mais les cecos en
grosse aider les banques de sperme à la
française pratique ce qu'on appelle le
pareillement le pareillement c'est quoi
en gros c'est trouver un donneur qui
ressemble physiquement au père stérile
histoire d'alimenter ou à minima
d'entretenir et de permettre le secret
ce qui veut dire que parmi vous ce soir
à qui l'on espère que différents de
leurs géniteurs et qui l'ignorent encore
et quelle importance au final me direz
vous notre père et notre père celui qui
a changé nos couches celui qui nous a
raconté une histoire le soir avant nous
endormir
celui qui nous a aidés à faire nos
devoirs nous a appris à faire du vélo
soyez nouveaux baux peu importe si on ne
partage pas exactement les mêmes gènes
ouais mon père et mon père là dessus
aucun doute j'appelle j'ai une mère mais
j'ai aussi un géniteur et je sais
aujourd'hui que ma conscience ma
personnalité mon comportement ont aussi
été facile
façonné par pas mon code génétique
croire que nous sommes des feuilles
blanches à la naissance est un leurre
tous les parents qui ont le plus d'un
enfant ici ce soir vous le diront on est
avec des personnalités différentes des
comportements différents des préférences
sexuelles différentes des différences
qui sont perceptibles déjà in utero
alors en effet notre éducation notre
environnement ont fait de nous les êtres
humains que nous sommes mais pas
seulement
on sait aujourd'hui que la transmission
génétique ne se limite pas uniquement
aux traits physiques que nos jeunes sont
aussi responsables en partie en tout cas
de notre intelligence notre personnalité
du fait qu'on soit consciencieux
extraverti ont tendance à dit ti vct qui
fait qu'on soit du matin ou du soir et
via l'épigénétique on sait aussi que les
traumatismes peut être parfois
transgénérationnel que la blessure
psychologique de grand papy peu à notre
insu affecté aussi une personnalité
ayant une histoire que j'adore là dessus
sur l'impact des jeunes c'est celle de
oscar store et jack iuf alors si vous la
connaissez mais mais jack et aux oscars
ce sont deux jumeaux séparés à la
naissance oscar a été envoyé dans une
famille catholique et nazis il rejoindra
même plus tard les jeunesses
hitlériennes
alors que jack lui fut élevé par les
familles juives à trinidad et bien ils
ont été réunis les adultes ils ont
fasciné les psychologues généticien et
neuroscientifique de l'époque alors
certes leur parcours ne pouvait être
plus diamétralement opposées et même si
vous vous en doutez un petit peu ce soir
jack et aux oscars n'ont jamais et
militer pour le même parti politique il
était étonnamment semblables tous les
deux étaient nuls en maths et fort en
sport tous les deux avaient les mêmes
intonations de voix et la même démarche
tous les deux le jour de leur rencontre
était habillée de la même manière avec
une petite chemisette bleue à épaulettes
tous les deux tirez la chasse avant et
après être allé aux toilettes
tous les deux commencé leurs romans par
la fin est tous les deux adoré le matin
prendre le petit déjeuner une tartine de
fromage la tremper dans leur café
non ça c'est peut-être le côté allemand
et enfin tous les deux adoré faire
semblant d'éternuer dans des ascenseurs
bandés histoire de faire sursauter tout
le monde les mêmes goûts culinaires a
même façon de marcher les mêmes
intonations de voix mêmes blagues le cas
de jack et oscar n'est pas du tout isolé
tous les tests psychologiques montrent
des similarités chez les jumeaux
messieurs les frères aussi moi qui suis
né d'un don anonyme moi qui ne connais
ni mon géniteur ni mes origines
moi qui appris de la bouche de ma mère
en plein divorce mes parents à l'âge de
10 ans et à deux heures du matin que mon
père n'est pas mon père moi qui enfin
face au médecin familial ne peut
répondre à la question très simple de
son vous antécédents familiaux qui
suis-je de quelle culture de quelle
lignée de galles pays à qui appartient
ce menton ce français tu bouges sonné et
information des plus importantes pour un
hypocondriaque
quels sont donc ces antécédents
familiaux
g j'ai eu besoin de savoir
j'ai voulu savoir et ce jour où ma mère
m'a annoncé la vérité sur la conception
et ses besoins devenus encore plus
prégnant jour moi même je suis devenu
papa
alors avec l'arrivée des des tests adn
récréatif qu'on peut acheter pour
quelques dizaines de dollars sur
internet
aujourd'hui je me suis jeté sur
l'occasion et j'ai envoyé un petit peu
de salive à un rien entreprises privées
américaines en espérant pouvoir
peut-être trouvé un demi frère ou une
demi-soeur peut-être un cousin je sais
rien trois ans plus tard je recevais mes
résultats et ces sites sont plutôt bien
fait sans vouloir en faire la promotion
non seulement ils vont vous montrer une
une origine géographique de vos origines
nord de l'europe bassin méditerranéen
etc
mais en plus ils vont vous mettre en
relation avec les autres utilisateurs du
site qui partage qui l'on connecté que
qui vont ceux qui vous sont connectés
génétiquement en fait moi qui ai grandi
fils unique et qui toujours rêvé d'avoir
une une fratrie biologique je me suis
jeté sur c'est sur ces résultats et a
malheureusement pas de demi frère pâte
demi soeur pas non plus deux cousins
germains et encore moins deux géniteurs
au match adn mon parent génétique le
plus proche était une vieille dame de 75
ans du connecticut aux états unis avec
qui je partageais 0,6 pour cent de dien
j'étais un peu déçu en fait là la
recherche de son géniteur
c'est un peu comme le loto ont scellé
sont faibles mais on y croit toujours un
petit peu alors pour comprendre ces
résultats et pour savoir aussi si la loi
un jour en france allait changer j'ai
décidé de rejoindre une association qui
regroupe les adultes issus du don
anonyme de sperme j'ai appris beaucoup
de choses jade une que je n'ai pas tout
seul dans cette quête d' à la recherche
de soi et de deux que 0,6 pour cent mais
c'était pas mal en fait et ça pouvait
même mené avec beaucoup de chance à mon
géniteur
alors on a cherché ensemble il s'en est
suivi une enquête biologie qui
généalogique de plusieurs jours et je
peux vous dire qu'en moins de 48 heures
j'avais retrouvé mon arrière grand père
paternel biologique grâce entre autres
aux archives d'ellis island donc et que
ça mais aussi dans le nord de l'europe
et dans les fins fonds du dark web et en
moins de 72 heures je vais retrouver
avec certitude mon grand père biologique
un homme qui a eu trois fils âgés
aujourd'hui entre 65 et 71 ans l'un
d'eux ne pouvait être que son géniteur
j'étais si proche en même temps si loin
comment l'identifier
parmi ses trois frères
et même si j'arrivais comment le contact
et aucun d'entre eux n'avait une adresse
e-mail ou n'était même sur les réseaux
sociaux
et puis quels mots utiliser salut voila
je sais qu'il ya 37 ans grosso modo un
tas dû faire un test à dos nîmes battu
voix sait pas si anonyme que ça alors du
coup j'ai préféré essayer de te
contacter leurs enfants qu'ils étaient
peut-être plus proche et même âge que
moi et j'ai cherché donc quelqu'un ait
le même patronyme sur les réseaux
sociaux et qui me ressemble un petit peu
j'ai trouvé quelqu'un rappelons le
nicolas pour préserver son anonymat ce
soir et donc j'ai contacté d'une manière
très simple je dis bonjour nicolas je
m'appelle jean et je pense que nous
avons le même grand père biologique
autant vous dire que c'est pas le genre
de message qui laisse complètement
indifférent
mais c'est pas forcément le genre de
message auquel on répond j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance parce qu'il m'a
répondu on s'est vite appelez d'abord
expliqué que dans baby n'avait pas
trompé mamie
et on a un petit peu j'ai détaillé mon
histoire et ensuite il m'a expliqué
qu'il était un petit peu étonné parce
que son père l avait jamais parlé d'un
dindon et qu'il était donc possible que
si l'oncle les faits il a quand même
voulu savoir donc il a fait un test adn
et rendre plus tard lui aussi recevait
ses résultats sur le même site et maman
parents génétiques le plus proche est
soudainement passé de 0,6 pour cent
cette fille d'anne dans le connecticut
que je remercie encore à 30%
montoni frères savez maintenant un demi
frère et même une demi soeur moi qui ai
grandi fils inc le week-end suivant il
en parlait à sa mère à sa soeur à son
père l'a finalement de famille autant
vous dire que la surprise fut grande
mais en dehors de nicolas qui j'avais
longuement discuté au téléphone
aucun d'entre eux ne souhaitait ni me
rencontrer ni me parler et c'est un peu
décevant certes mais c'est pas très
grave parce que maintenant
j'avais un nom j'avais un pays d'origine
c'est pas la france j'avais une culture
j'avais une histoire et j'avais
finalement ces séances précédant
familiaux vous cherchez temps et puis
l'information la plus importante
je sais que mon géniteur 70 ans il a
toujours ses cheveux
quelques semaines plus tard j'ai
rencontré pour la première fois de ma
vie mon demi frère nicolas
mais n'était pas venue seule avec son
fils et sa femme mais aussi avec sa
soeur et sa mère et son père et non
seulement après le choc de l'annoncé
il avait souhaité me rencontrer mais en
plus ils étaient venus avec des photos
des écrits d histoire une famille
adorable unis on est resté en contact
j'en compte se voir souvent j'aimerais
mieux représenter mon fils les
sentiments que j'ai ressenti à ce moment
là soit absolument indescriptible c'est
unix appartient de la team et j'aurais
du mal à les retranscrire ce soir par
contre les choses soient bien claires je
ne cherchais pas un père chercher mes
origines et j'ai trouvé mon père et mon
père et cette évidence est devenu
beaucoup plus facile à embrasser
après cette découverte j'ai un père et
une mère
mais maintenant j'ai une histoire un
petit peu plus complète grâce à mon
géniteur gt
suez construit par trois personnes et ce
soir je veux les remercier en tant
qu'être humain on a tendance à se
fabriquer des cases dans lesquelles tout
ranger tout simplifier la vie c'est pas
simple c'est un gros bordel et pour des
dizaines de milliers de français dont
vous faites peut-être partie sans même
le savoir
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça
c'est décalé merci
[Applaudissements]